let's talk about this next door we got
this from deadline the view apologizes
after linking turning point usa to
neo-nazi demonstrators
i don't think the apology was good
enough no it's not they said uh haynes
sarah hayne said so on monday we talked
about the fact that there were openly
neo-nazi demonstrators outside the
florida student action summit of the
turning point usa group we want to make
clear that these demonstrators were
gathered outside the event that they
were not invited or endorsed by invited
or endorsed by turning point usa a
turning point usa spokesman said the
group quote 100 condemns these those
ideologies and said turning point you
say security tried to remove the
neo-nazis from the area but could not
because they were on public property
also turning point you say one wanted us
to clarify this was a turning point you
say summit and not a republican party
event so we apologize for anything we
said that may have been unclear on these
points this is the problem it wasn't
what they said was unclear it was what
they said was untrue right i didn't get
the original statement they said that
there were neo-nazis at turning point
whoopi goldberg said initially you let
him in though okay you let him in so
they lied they didn't say something
right clear that they lied they come
back from commercial and they're like we
got issue a clarification they they
weren't and she goes they weren't in the
building but they were all you know in
the in the in the mix you apologize for
lying not for being unclear it's
different you lied whoopi
maybe maybe she thought it was real and
she said something that she thought was
real this is again what would
they should sue
oh yeah this is like for as much as
money as they can the nazis were
protesting the events right in
opposition to it but one of the ways you
actually get some sort of accountability
is pain a big believer that there have
to be consequences and sue them yeah
because they can do something
on whoopi's neck like you can't keep
bringing me yeah you can't yeah you
can't be doing this and at some point
the legal counsel is going to come say
hey stop you can't be well they they did
this this is the crazy thing i think
they know after like another maybe a
massive lawsuit that they lose and
settlements
when whitby defamed them they came back
and she said i have to issue a notice
they weren't in the building the
producers clearly went to her and said
you can't lie like that and then she she
they come back from commercial or
whatever and she's like okay everybody
they weren't in the building but maybe
some producers have some moral ethics on
the view still it's not about morality
it's about fear
losing your job
and so i think turning point should
still sue because
i'd argue this was not enough
they needed to clarify the people who
were there were actually protesting and
hate turning point usa
there was no connection the groups were
the turning point you say people were
screaming at them and they were they
were like yelling at each other the view
is just this is the game they play
you lie you issue a weak retraction and
say we know that you can't handle a
lawsuit so deal with it this is also
like just an expose as usual of the
ignorance that many of these mainstream
outlets shows have of right-wing
politics in general like whenever i even
when i read academic articles about like
the alt-right or something they're all
so unbelievably incorrect like anyone
who calls charlie kirk like far right or
all right it's like you you literally
know nothing about the dynamics of the
right the right know everything about
the dynamics of the left they understand
them inward and outward all the
different factions and groups but
there's it's like a complete blind spot
the right are just like nazis all of
them and did you see the crowder crowder
put out a video where he's talking to
some college students and one guy calls
him alt-right he's like what he's like
what does that mean and then everyone
like there's a black dude there and he's
like crowder's not alt-right he's like i
watch crowder all the time what are you
talking about and the guy says all right
it's like you and ben shapiro and he's
like ben shapiro's jewish they don't
know what it means they don't they're
they're mindless zombies and this is the
problem they get lied to by the view and
other news outlets and then they walk
around saying things that make literally
no sense but i'll tell you this if you
want to control people keep them in a
constant state of confusion where they
don't know what's happening as they say
the truth shall set you free whoopi just
said that jill biden should be our
surgeon general that was a while she's a
phenomenal doctor
that was a while ago yeah and totally
ridiculous because she's like an
education a doctor an education not
really not a medical doctor not really
even a doctor at all in any way yeah
it's like an educational uh honorary
honor
i i don't know oh she got yeah an
honorary one nice
let me make
yeah i think that i think there is a
real skin care doctors oh educator
educator yeah it's not a phd it's
something else let me see if i can uh
find it but that's a
going back to
the lab it's edd yeah the thing that's
curious to me about the left there's no
actual curiosity
doctor of education okay so it comes
from it's not a phd in the kids e-d-d
that's what she has i think it's more
than that educationist doctor
so you're saying so you're saying that
people on the left in this in this cult
or whatever this is this weird there's
no intellectual curiosity they don't
really want to understand because
from the outset they're all wrong so why
should we have any curiosity in trying
to understand where they're coming from
so i i mean they literally have no
curiosity about trying to examine any of
our ideas or have a conversation because
our conscience is wrong our beliefs are
wrong our actions are wrong so we don't
need to even engage with you on this at
all we do have an update here from
turning point usa though they say
tomorrow join the protest thursday july
28th 7 a.m outside gma studios in times
square 10 a.m outside the view studio
320 west 66th street uh i'll just say
this
if you are in times square can you get a
photo of those billboards we have we're
really trying i'm just kidding yeah get
one of me yeah
i haven't seen a photo yet uh i just
want to stress that point though while
y'all are protesting gma and i think
there's a billboard of me above their
building so like this is the point i'm
trying to make with those times square
ads we're coming for their cultural
spaces we are challenging them we are
winning and they are getting really
really angry remind me again is there is
there an ad for chicken city yes there
is okay good two of them actually two of
them okay i just want to make sure
because 96 foot tall billboards for
chicken city but chicken city gets some
love yeah well i deserve it yeah i want
i'm fascinated by this whole concept
great well so the the general idea with
times square is that
our ads are going to be right next to
good morning america and when regular
people look up they're going to see us
on par equal to them and we're going to
call them out as liars and we're going
to be of same status and stature on
equal footing when we do it is that
something you could do like if you knew
there was an ad beside you that was like
for the view or something could you get
like a you know i'm with stupid arrow or
something like you can do that yes
they they might reject it right but i
think as long as i i think most of these
companies that do ads just want money
so when you know i put up a
this this billboard we have in times
square is so big i don't know what to do
with it so they're they're going to take
down the ad soon that the run the run is
ending and then they were like we'll
send it to you and i'm like it's 40 feet
tall are you finishing that i wonder if
we could get you like something three
out of ten
okay
15 foot and all going like three
different movies going at once so the
point was that we put that on top of the
good morning america building so we've
got a 70-foot uh
ad
on the top of the good morning america
building so i wanted everybody to see us
above them and make that point i think
it's good branding good marketing good
brand awareness and all that stuff as
they keep getting dragged keep lying and
failing and screwing up we're going to
be there to take those cultural spaces
back so hash take them over sue the view
which is the tp
are you not going to join me in using a
paper cup no
no i am not i will i know this guy
thinks he's so much better than that no
no
i'm just
okay with my class
it's disrespectful
respect the pappy and there it goes
that's right that's it cheers to the
last year
has been the last of the pap yeah i've
been
after it happy happy happy happy
costly have they officially declared
that they're suing the view or is this
just like let's just i don't think press
i don't think they said that yet but
hashtag sue the view is the is the
hashtag for the event i think uh i'm
assuming joe hernandez is going to be
down there and so drew if you're out
there uh i look forward to seeing all
the footage in the coverage of what's
going on with people protesting they
should be they should be exciting um i'm
glad to see that uh people on the right
are organizing peaceful protests yeah
and it's punching back yeah yeah i think
this is the one thing that i loved about
trump is that he rejected the premise he
wasn't going to take any he punched back
and i'd like to see this more across the
movement where
you come at us and we will come right
back at you even stronger it's rapid too
like when you're disciplining a dog if
it pees on the ground you don't wait 20
minutes and then come back and yell
because it doesn't know why you're
yelling but if you do it right when it's
doing it it knows not to do that there
needs to be accountability because so
long as these as the left can burn down
buildings without law enforcement
intervening and it's insane i'll tell
you this i think
actu can i just say why hasn't
any uh republican filed a lawsuit to
disqualify joe biden and kamala harris
for running for office for waging
insurrection against the united states
by funding the bail for insurrectionists
on during the summer of love they want
to all that happens is the democrats
come out and scream insurrection for you
know non-stop for months right there's
no insurrection but if that's the game
they want to play they lost these
lawsuits okay well kamala harris
directly bailed out people who were
riding in minnesota and minnesota okay
sewer 14th amendment she waged
insurrection against the united states
she provided material support to people
who engage in insurrection against this
country
well they don't do it can i but this is
part of the problem
like on a 30 000 foot level on their
side are religious zealots
right the politics for them is their
religion they are religious zealots they
are committed to it by all means
necessary they will have political power
we're a bunch of careerists i'm gonna go
to dc i'm gonna have a nice career at a
think tank or in congress and after 20
30 years be like hey that was a lot of
fun no they're they're interested in
fundamental change they will do
everything they're committed to it and
we're like i'm just here for a good
career
we have to completely unless we actually
become more religious zealots on our
side
you're gonna see more of this why aren't
we doing that it's part of why i don't
consider myself conservative because i
do think we need literal like radical
liberal change but for for good not like
zealous ch it doesn't need to be like my
way or the highway but the system needs
to be drastically altered the federal
reserve has annihilated our economy we
need to take back control of our
financials yeah but i don't think we get
back to normal unless we actually meet
some of their religious zealotry with
our own i i i again i tell people we're
not going to get back to normal until we
beat the left the problem and
unconditional surrender they there is no
i think we have to come to this is not
your granddaddy's democratic party
this is an un-american left
that has nothing to do with the founding
ideals i'm not sure where we have common
ground with them nothing well that's
right so i mean how do you actually come
to that point there is no common ground
the only way you get to a common ground
is to beat them into submissions i think
unconditional common ground on epstein
you know both the left and the right
were like hey what's up with that
someone someone went to jail for
a massive underage prostitution ring but
we don't know who who who are they
selling to right but the left and the
right both agree that there's something
bad going on there epstein didn't thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there